[Música]
entramos a nuestra revista de prensa de
directo América en esta mañana de lunes
con Rosa Pérez más de urros un saludo
para usted Buenos días Ángela Buenos
días pero no tanto las noticias O al
menos polémicas vamos a empezar con la
editorial del medio del faro sobre el
Salvador y esta mega cárcel que inauguró
el presidente nayib bukele sin más y sin
democracia se titula de este artículo
exactamente este editorial que da
bastante explícita No su tesis en el
propio título y es que se ha conseguido
una cosa en detrimento de la otra la
tesis la encontramos en los primeros
párrafos que dice la ausencia de
pandillas visible por primera vez en
mucho tiempo es un cambio fundamental en
la vida de miles de salvadoreños sobre
todo para los que han vivido durante
décadas bajo el control de estos grupos
criminales por lo que la ausencia no de
pandillas tiene un enorme potencial dice
transformador para el país dice pero el
precio que hemos tenido que pagar es
demasiado alto y bien según el Edi del
faro este precio es como queda explícito
en el título la propia democracia no
dice se ha cedido y se ha permitido que
todos los poderes queden concentrados en
manos de una sola persona evidentemente
del presidente nayib bukele no dice que
ostenta el poder no Ángela de una forma
autoritaria concretamente a través de
este régimen de excepción que dura Ya 10
meses no sin rendición de cuentas por
parte de la fuerza pública poco con la
suspensión de derechos fundamentales
amparada en este régimen de excepción
como bien decíamos no y siempre pues
sabemos que cuando se logra esclarecer
un poco las actuaciones de las
autoridades no Durante este tiempo en
que hay tanta suspensión de los derechos
fundamentales no siempre digamos pues
son prácticas muy democráticas no las
que tienen exactamente estuvo en El
Salvador y en muchos otros países dice
Por qué se ha permitido llegar a esta
situación Pues porque la mayoría de
salvadoreños consideran que la
democracia ya no sirve para nada porque
no ha sido capaz de resolver los
problemas más urgentes y más importantes
del país como era concretamente la
inseguridad y el terror causado por
estas pandillas sin embargo para
concluir ya un poco con las ideas de
este editorial dice las pandillas
tampoco surgen por generación espontánea
no sino que han sido el resultado de una
sociedad corrupta marcada por la pobreza
la desigualdad la imposibilidad de
movilización social de acceso a la
educación a la salud a la vivienda al
empleo y que estas condiciones tampoco
han cambiado en la represión no las ha
solucionado no dice De hecho hemos
vuelto a un sistema de caudillismo
corrupto y el remedio podría ser tan
nocivo como la enfermedad Bueno pero de
allí sin embargo esta gran popularidad
de nayib bukele en el país vamos a
cambiar de tema y hablar de los Globos
de espionaje chinos siguen en los
titulares entre los grandes medios
internacionales como el financial Times
y también el Wall Street journal
exactamente Ángela está polémica no
desaparece de las principales portadas
Internacionales concretamente El
financial Times dice carga contra
Estados Unidos por derribar el globo
aumentando la tensión en unas relaciones
desgastadas de Wall Street journal
Estados Unidos dice que los Globos
anteriores no fueron detectados Y es que
aquí tenemos dos aristas de esta
polémica en Estados Unidos por un lado
los republicanos sospechan aprobar en la
cámara una resolución de condena a la
administración de biden por su manejo
tardío dicen de la situación del globo
que como bien comentabas en los
informativos Ángela acabó siendo
derribado por un avión de combate el
pasado sábado no sin embargo la
administración biden reveló que durante
el mandato de Donald Trump también se
detectaron estos supuestos globos espía
chino algo que el ex Secretario de
Defensa de Trump Marc esper nevó ante la
sienen en este artículo que estamos
viendo ahí detrás por otra Arista
obviamente es la desgastada relación
entre China y Estados Unidos no
precisamente encontramos en el people's
dainy este medio no alineado con el
partido comunista de China la entrada de
la aeronave civil fue accidental e
inesperada y Beijing califica de
desmesurada no de sobredimensionada la
de exagerada no la reacción de
Washington y señala que solo socava los
esfuerzos y el y el progreso logrado por
las dos partes en la mejora de las
relaciones algo en lo que coinciden
distintos expertos también citados en el
souths y nuestro último tema que cambia
radicalmente el tono de este segmento
pero que en el que amanecimos
completamente inundados No solo en
medios de comunicación sino en redes
sociales y es este récord que alcanza
Beyoncé pero que pareciera un poco
agridulce Porque así es Ángela porque
ayer la artista sumó cuatro premios
Grammy con lo que en total y acumula 32
a lo largo de su carrera y ostenta si el
récord del artista que más premios
Grammy ha ganado no en la historia
concretamente ganó por mejor álbum Dance
electrónica por el álbum René Sounds por
mejor grabación danza electrónica por
mejor interpretación tradicional de
riman blues y mejor canción de rihan
Plus sin embargo no ganó el premio al
mejor álbum no Y esta es un poco la
crítica y este sabor agridulce que
comentan distintos medios de
comunicación hagamos un repaso súper
rápido los titulares empezamos por lo
mono que dice Beyoncé se convierte en la
artista más premiada en la historia de
Los Grammys se sienta sola en su trono
pero en este sentido más agridulce el
crítico musical del Washington post
Chris richards dice Beyoncé acaba de
hacer historia de los Grammy Pero por
qué Parece que haya perdido dice el
premio más codiciado de los Grammy álbum
del año ya se le había escapado tres
veces a Beyoncé lo que no significa un
reflejo de la calidad artística de
Beyoncé sino una prueba del fracaso
constante de la academia para celebrar
la música negra en el apogeo de su
relevancia cultural iba a ser esta noche
distinta no lo mismo señala Rolling
Stone se rompió el récord de los Grammy
pero no es suficiente al relé 11 a
premios menores la academia de grabación
no reconoce al artista que la empuja a
hacer Mejor no porque la noche más
grande de la están reacia darles a las
mujeres negras lo que les corresponde
bien Esta es un poco la pregunta con la
que cierra Rolling sto